- This video is brought to you by Keeps.
(upbeat music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here to talk about the main cause
of carpal tunnel syndrome
in 35 and unders:
swiping on dating apps.
If you're looking for love online,
chances are you've racked up
a fair share of heartbreak,
or at least mild disappointment.
While offering a seemingly infinite supply
of potential suitors,
dating apps can feel like
an endless cycle of swiping,
forced witty banter, awkward
coffee dates, mutual ghosting,
and, ultimately, going to bed alone.
So how did we get here?
Is online dating a unique
techno-sexual dystopia,
or the natural culmination
of centuries of courtship rituals?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack Edition
"Online Dating: Is Love Just a Commodity?"
But before we dive in,
I wanna tell you about
this week's sponsor, Keeps.
Keeps makes it easier for
guys to prevent hair loss.
With their affordable
prescription service,
you can maintain the hair you have
with convenient at-home treatments.
The process begins with
a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps
doctor who can recommend
a combination of
FDA-approved prescriptions
and over-the-counter medications
that's right for you.
These hair loss prevention medications
will land at your door every three months,
so you don't have to
dedicate any brain space
to remembering refills.
As your treatment plan goes on,
you can message your Keeps doctor 24/7
to update them on your progress
and ask any questions you may have.
It typically takes between
four and six months
to start seeing results,
so get started today
to hang on to the hair you have.
Go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the description
to receive 50% off your first order.
That's K-E-E-P-S.com/wisecrack.
Now, back to the show.
To contextualize the modern dating scene,
let's look to history.
For much of dating history,
heterosexual courtship was
all about getting a ring
on that finger.
Most women weren't allowed to work,
and thus sought financial
stability via marriage,
while men were incentivized
by that sweet, sweet dowry.
- What's wrong with her?
She's beautiful, she's
rich, she's got huge
tracts of land.
- [Michael] Courtship was
largely a private enterprise
arranged between families,
with women essentially
functioning as bartering tools
to solidify social alliances.
Potential candidates were
evaluated based on class
and social status.
Sociologist Eva Illouz also
notes that most young people
were pressured to accept
their first reasonable option.
Love was nice if it happened,
but this was mostly a
regimented transaction.
- Not all of us can afford to be romantic.
I've been offered a comfortable
home and protection.
That's a lot to be thankful for.
- Charlotte.
- I'm 27 years old.
I've no money and no prospects.
- [Michael] But then,
in 1840, Queen Victoria
and legendary Wife Guy Prince
Albert entered the chat.
- For me, this is not a
marriage of convenience.
(dramatic music)
- No.
I think it will be a
marriage of inconvenience.
- [Michael] They were famously
head-over-heels in love,
a romance that got only more legendary
when Victoria publicly mourned Albert
for 40 years after his death.
Royals, as you may know,
were basically the original influencers.
So this romance, coupled
with the mainstreaming
of Enlightenment ideals
about personal fulfillment,
helped make marrying for romantic love
start to seem important, and even noble.
For upper-class women,
this era of courtship
meant suitors leaving calling cards
and arranging chaperoned meetings.
Like Bumble, but your frowning
step-mom is also there,
just sitting and judging.
What's important is that
courtship now entailed
assessing compatibility between families,
personalities and so on,
rather than just settling
for the first Joe Schmo
who threw a stone at your window.
Working-class women, somewhat
empowered by the wage economy,
were less bound by ceremony,
and often lived in apartments too small
for men to come calling anyway.
They met men on their
way to work, in shops,
or at music halls.
They dated, had sex,
juggled a bevy of admirers,
and it wasn't uncommon to be
pregnant on your wedding day.
Dating around wasn't just a fun time,
it was also considered essential
to finding the right match
in what Illouz calls
the, "Emergence of a self-regulated
market of encounters."
But here's the thing.
In the dating culture that emerged
at the end of the 19th century,
money became even more central
to the direct interactions of the couple,
because now dating meant going on dates,
and going on dates tends to cost money.
As scholar Beth L. Bailey explains,
"Courtship was largely
construed and understood
"in models and metaphors of
modern industrial capitalism."
As dates moved from living
rooms into dance halls and bars,
money was what Bailey calls
a, "Symbolic currency of exchange,"
where men needed to pay to
gain access to women's company.
By the 1920s, she notes,
"Dating provided a new frontier
"for public competition
through consumption."
As a result, young people
started defining
themselves as commodities:
men by how much they could afford
to spend on theater tickets,
women by how much they
were worth spending on.
This fittingly coincided
with the explosive growth
of the consumer economy,
which transformed ideals of romantic love.
If men now needed to have money
to burn on vaudeville shows,
women now needed to look
like pre-war Kardashians.
That's in large part due to
the increased sexualization
of women in the media and advertising.
Industries like cosmetics
relied on enticing imagery
to create demand for new products.
As Illouz notes, before the 1920s,
the word sexy was actually
considered derogatory.
It was more preferable to
shack up with somebody who was,
say, super moral or reliable.
But as mass media began pumping out images
of eroticized female bodies,
and, soon enough, male bodies,
sexual attraction began
figuring into people's choices
in a much bigger way.
As marital selection became
increasingly less based
on your social status and
more on subjective things
like sex appeal, the ability
to land a regulation hottie
started factoring more
into people's conceptions
of individual self worth.
As Illouz puts it, under modernity,
"Sexuality thus becomes
closely intertwined
with social value."
But of course, nothing
spoils the sex party
quite like a pair of world wars.
Couples were split apart,
with courtship relegated
out of the dance hall
and back to the post office.
But it went beyond these basic logistics.
The idea of a chaste woman who stayed home
loyally awaiting the troops'
return became hugely popular,
especially during World War I.
And that chaste woman became something
of a commodified trophy for
men down in the trenches
to fantasize and sing about.
♪ My girl back home ♪
♪ I'd almost forgot ♪
♪ A blue-eyed kid ♪
♪ I liked her a lot ♪
- While the fellas were away,
working-class and middle-class
women also spent more time
in the public sphere, doing
man stuff like going to job
and sometimes wearing trousers.
But especially after World War
II, the return of the troops,
plus rising pressure to marry
early, pushed a lot of women
back into the home.
Some of the rush to get
married was out of anxiety
about the scarcity of
eligible men post-war,
which reinforces a marketplace vibe.
But this also had other
important economic implications.
Whereas married women
had once been treated
like pure commodities,
housewives were now the main
consumers of commodities.
Men went to work, produced
goods, accumulated capital,
and their wives spent that
money buying more goods.
Thus, the marriage industrial
complex became vital
to keeping the consumption-driven
1950s economy humming.
Meanwhile, for the burgeoning youth
consumer culture of the 1950s,
going steady became a
coming-of-age dating ritual
in its own right,
complete with varsity pins
and a sexy game called
Two Straws, One Milkshake.
♪ Did they really get pinned ♪
♪ Going steady ♪
♪ I was hoping they would ♪
- By the mid-1950s, 1 in
10 middle school students
would go steady at least
once before turning 11.
Of course, I better than
doubled those stats myself.
Going steady is essentially the origin
for how we conceive of dating today,
in all its serial monogamy.
And make no mistake, just
as it was for their parents,
consumption was inextricable
from this boom in young love.
Shopping and investment
became metaphors for dating.
You needed a car to neck in,
a class ring to exchange,
a letterman jacket to drape
over your date's shoulders,
records to dance to and
turntables to play them on,
meals at the malt shop, and so on.
And dating remains a
consumption-driven activity
to this day, even if we've
swapped banana splits
for charcuterie boards,
and class rings for Netflix passwords.
Now, the 1960s and '70s,
as you probably know,
brought varying degrees
of free love and rebellion
against the previous decades' sexual
and romantic constraints.
But by the 1980s, we saw a
return to conservative values
in pretty much every
element of American society.
It's around this time that
the 1950s were reimagined
as a nostalgic utopia of happy families
born from people who'd
just lost their virginity.
The free-market-obsessed
'80s also saw the ascendancy
of dating technology,
like computer-based dating services,
or the truly heinous video dating boom.
- Hi, I'm Maurice.
I'm an executive by day,
and a wild man by night.
- These companies
promised to help you, say,
"Do comparison shopping of potential dates
"from the comfort and
privacy of your own home."
Again, we see the language of capitalism
continuing to permeate dating.
And then, came the internet.
Now, technically, the earliest version
of computerized dating
came from Harvard in 1965,
when some students created Operation Match
a half-century before your
favorite sunscreen enthusiast
would start your least-favorite
social networking site
in hopes of getting laid.
This 75-question-long survey helped
tens of thousands of people
learn about well-suited
potential new mates
in its first year alone.
And its algorithmic match
process has since been emulated
by modern dating sites.
These companies also used the knowledge
gained from those questionnaires
to mine consumer data,
a practice that would only
grow in the years to come.
As the internet entered more
homes, companies like AOL
funneled people into chatrooms,
bulletin boards, and so on,
based on mutual interests,
which inevitably led to dating.
The first dating site,
Kiss.com, launched in 1994,
followed shortly thereafter
by Match.com in 1995.
And by 1998, Nora Ephron
made the world a better place
with the film "You've Got Mail."
Side note: we actually made a video
about how that delightful
film is secretly fascist,
so check it out.
Now, early online daters
encountered plenty of stigma
and were often painted as desperate.
But the more online our lives have gotten,
the more mainstream
online dating has become.
By 2007, Americans
alone spent $500 million
on online dating services,
making it the
second-most-profitable sector
of the internet economy.
And we all know what
the highest industry is.
The one you have to open
up the anonymous browser
to go look at so it's not in your history
so that if your mom uses your computer
that things doesn't happen
again like it did that one time.
So it comes as no surprise
that online dating services
are expected to rake in over
3 billion dollars this year
in the United States alone,
especially in light of how a
cornucopia of new dating sites
and apps have cropped up,
boasting new innovations
like Tinder's gamified swiping interface
or Bumble's women-led dating model.
A benefit of online dating
is the way it creates
opportunities for people
from specific communities
to connect with each other:
LGBTQ+ folks, people in rural areas,
elderly or disabled people,
hell, even fly fishermen.
It can also be a relatively
unthreatening way
to meet new people,
and sometimes to screen out
potentially-bad matches.
But we see something else going on
that we think does a lot to
explain why online dating
can feel so hard, and
occasionally, pretty depressing.
Now, we've talked about the intersection
between dating and economics,
from dowries to theatre dates
to the consumer demand
for engagement rings
that cost a month's salary.
But we'd argue that online
dating basically takes
the commodification of
the actual act of dating
that cropped up around
the turn of the century
and turned it up to eleven.
- Put it up to 11.
- 11, exactly.
- How?
Well, as scholars Rebecca
D. Heino, Nicole B. Ellison,
and Jennifer L. Gibbs
note in their article
"Relationshopping," dating
sites are typically designed
like online shopping platforms,
evoking the sensation of
literally window-shopping
for a match.
They write that, "The
functionality and design
"of online dating sites
encouraged participants
"to adopt a marketplace orientation
"towards the online dating experience."
Now, that doesn't necessarily
make Tinder sinister,
but it could have real implications
for the kinds of relationships
you're most likely to find.
In "Relationshopping," the
authors write that online dating
may encourage an attitude
where prospective partners are,
"Commodified as products to be sold,
"assessed, purchased, or discarded."
Being discarded is probably fine
if you were only looking
for a one-time hookup,
but it lends a depressing air
if you're in search of a
long-term relationship.
Illouz notes that it also leads
to hyper-critical assessments
that render, "Potential partners
commensurable, measurable,
"and comparable with each other."
And if sexual attractiveness
became a big deal in the '20s,
it's only been magnified in importance,
because these apps
facilitate a lightning-fast
superficial decision making process
typically based on a
few flattering photos.
Online dating also massively expands
your pool of potential matches,
creating a sense of interchangeability.
How many Daniels can you match with
before they all blend into
the same guy in cargo shorts?
And this replicates the overall sensation
we have as consumers today,
where we're similarly empowered to choose
between a dizzying array
of 125 toothpaste brands.
What's more, in the
logic of online dating,
potential matches are
reduced and scrutinized
by isolated attributes,
making them easier to reject or discard.
Research has found that
the ease of discarding
online dating partners may even continue
into a relationship.
That's partly because of the lack
of an integrated social environment,
i.e. shared friends or communities,
which makes it feel easier to ghost.
Overall, Illouz argues,
"Internet dating sites
"display the consumerist logic
of increasingly narrowing,
"defining, and refining tastes,
"and comparing among
alternative possibilities."
While it's obviously good to be picky
when it comes to choosing
a long-term partner,
applying consumerist logic
to actual human beings
seems less picky, more icky.
And it's not just your potential dates
that are being commodified here.
The authors of
"Relationshopping" also note
that online dating encourages
self-commodification
via a, "Tangible and explicit assessment
"of one's own perceived desirability
"in ways less likely to occur
"with traditional
face-to-face communication."
That is to say, participants
in online dating
are constantly receiving reams of data
that cause them to assess
their own objective value
in the dating world.
Which can feel pretty harsh.
So what does this all say about us?
Well, modernity, Illouz explains,
has been all about the
rise of the rational
in just about every aspect of life,
from psychology to weight-loss fads.
Online dating reflects the
rationalization of love,
where we're encouraged
to assess potential dates
as laundry lists of attributes
rather than messy, complex human beings.
The endless supply of consumer choices
that defines late capitalism
has been effectively mapped
onto human relationships.
While some of us may romanticize
the 1950s model of going steady long-term,
the tech we're using to find relationships
may be counterproductive
in achieving that goal.
Think about it.
After World War II, women
settled into marriage quickly
due to the scarcity of eligible men.
In contrast, the seeming
abundance of matches
provided by online dating might incline us
to not settle down at all, or
to discard a potential mate
simply because there
might be a shinier object
just a click away.
Don't get us wrong, exploring
your options is great.
But when it's treated
like the same process
as finding the right Netflix show,
it starts to feel a little cynical?
And the commodification of human beings
on dating sites goes even deeper.
Hinge might brand itself as the,
"Dating app designed to be deleted,"
but it's actually in all
the apps' best interests
to keep you scrolling
through face after face.
And their casino-style
interfaces make it all too easy
to waste an evening doing just that.
Ultimately, these companies
make a great deal of money
by collecting super valuable data
about some of the most
intimate aspects of your life.
After all, these aren't old friends
interested in helping you find love,
they're tech platforms
interested in earning a buck.
Or a billion of them.
So it seems that dating has
become more complicated,
and more commodified, than ever before.
Finding a mate, a prospect
once simply determined
by your family's financial capital,
is now an important means
of affirming your worth,
of broadcasting your individual social
and/or cultural capital.
Qualities like your sense
of humor or your great hair,
Illouz says, thus start to become,
"Indexes of your inner value."
In other words, if you
used to be able to blame
your bankrupt dad for hurting your chances
of landing a wife, now
you're implicitly told
to blame yourself for
not being witty enough
in your About Me section.
So what are we supposed to do?
We're years off from designing
our perfect partner in a lab,
free-love communes are
harder and harder to find,
and sex robots can be hacked
and turned into murder-bots.
So are we stuck as self-aware commodities
in an ever-expanding marketplace
of increasingly disposable
romantic products?
Well, barring some kind
of cultural backlash,
online dating will probably keep becoming
increasingly intrinsic
to our courtship rituals.
We can't change that.
But maybe recognizing the
unusual historical moment
of dating that we're in can
help us be a little less hard
on ourselves when the
process feels hopeless.
And maybe thinking about how
weird it is to treat yourself
like a commodity can help us
be a little less judgemental
towards men who post photos
of themselves with tigers.
'Cause at the end of the day,
we're all looking for some
iteration of the same thing:
human connection, whether
for a night or forever.
Well, that and romantic partners
who look like they're auditioning
for a Tiger King biopic.
But what do you guys think?
Do you wish your romantic life
was still determined by dowries?
Is online dating killing romance?
Or is shopping for dates
fun and empowering?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out our podcast.
Hit that subscribe button like
it's a Superlike on Tinder,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(cheerful music)
Shout out to all my soldiers
online dating actively.
It sounds rough.
Bring back arranged marriage.
Okay, here we go.